after finishing high school he earned
$20,000 selling Italian ice at a local
beach he published a memoir the wolf of
Wall Street which was adapted into a
highly successful movie before becoming
the wolf of Wall Street he wanted to be
a dentist he is Jordan Belfort and
here's my take on his top ten roses
success volume 3 enjoy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one get pumped up guys I want you
to Schumer and me one time let's go come
on huh come on
[Music]
Oh God huh huh all right stop guess what
I never actually did that here's what I
did do though the story is is that when
they were filming that scene it was the
first scene Matthew McConaughey was
filming and he right before they start
he goes off into the corner and
Scorsese's there and the Caprio and he
goes uh uh-huh am I sick what the hell
is this guy doing he's like huh huh huh
and Leo's like it's like his kind of
like little chance he does to get
himself into state and Moore is like I
love this because we have to make this
part of the movie and it actually became
this whole war cry throughout the movie
and everyone just loved it now there's
like you know you're looking at
Tomorrowland and all in the soccer guys
in the world couple of doing eyes it's
hysterical but here's the deal what
Matthew McConaughey is doing he's
getting himself into a state for a king
the state of certainty confidence
clarity right and today you've probably
heard this we call that state management
but back in the day when I was first you
know cutting my teeth and training the
Strad Knights right and excuse me
we called it staying positive not
getting negative and I knew intuitively
from my own experience that I'll tell
you it's a novel you're gonna love it
right that if my brokers got negative
they wouldn't produce unless they were
pumped up in a pitch state so every
morning we'd stand up I had them squeeze
the hand seller and say the word yes so
just yes and again yes until the woman
so let's do that real quick ready 1 2 3
yes 1 2 3 louder 1 2 3 rule number 2
master your craft let me tell you what
this is this is probably one of the most
important things when it comes to
success in every endeavor you go for
whatever job every whatever business you
start there's gonna be certain
specialized skills that are required and
you need to become extraordinary at them
let me tell your story
how did this whole thing happen in my
life right hand I write this book okay
how did I go out and take this book and
turn it into this whole business that
formed the movie and a global brand
right
well let me taste like I was in jail
okay and when I show up the jail who's
my bunkmate believe it or not Tom Lee
Chong from Cheech and Chong
you know Cheech and Chong he's my
bunkmate right now I didn't go to I
wasn't in the worst jail though I'll
admit I wasn't getting but each night my
bones not there it was a federal prison
camp
okay it was okay well but still jails
Jail it sucks right Tommy's my bunk Nick
you're both celebrity put us together in
one cube it was a little cube unity he's
writing a book right so Tommy says to me
oh my god we told each other stories at
night and I haven't rolling on the floor
laughing that so by night three girls
you know I thought you were making this
up but my wife gold.you it's all true
you live this crazy lifeless you got to
write a book you got to get it right
about this stuff so I said well I don't
know how to write he says well just
write the way you speak the way you tell
a story so well guess what I tried that
doesn't work writing and speaking are
very different skill sets they just are
completely different and for the first
month or so I'm writing a couple of
pages I showed them to Tommy
he reads those wow that really sucks
like thanks Tommy don't you really think
right and I was depressed because I
couldn't get anything out in paper that
was meaningful or funny right and I
always was gonna stop and I hate
quitting anything and I went to the
prison library one day this prisons his
library and I stumbled upon a book
called bonfire of the vanities by Tom
Wolfe and I started reading this book
and it's like oh my god and this is how
I want to write so I plow through the
book finish it I start back at page
where I take out a yellow highlighter
and I use this book like the textbook
and for three months I ripped apart
every single word I broke down Tom
Wolfe's strategy for writing sometimes
it doesn't matter how much you want
something or how hard you willing to
work to get something if you don't
possess the actual skill set that's
required to do it it's delusion and most
people don't get that they'll try to go
into a business that's sales based but
not master the art of sales and
persuasion
try to go into another side business not
mess whatever it might be they don't
master that craft but the first thing
you have to say okay I want to do this
what specialized skills ready to learn
and take the time to learn them master
your craft rule number three don't care
what haters think when I wrote the book
I knew I put myself out there for public
yeah I get a lot of detractors but you
know what I mean you know in the end and
the Internet I think if Jesus Christ
gave a sermon on the Temple Mount his
famous sermon you'd have people trolls
there's nothing new there that's bull
he's felt like you've done what you do
people are gonna say it sucks right yeah
saying and you live in that sort of
world where you just have people that
are gonna love you and people they're
gonna hate you so I think that the
haters serve a purpose so you know I
don't really think much about it
rule number four get rid of limiting
beliefs a belief a limiting belief is
like putting the governor on the engine
of a Ferrari before I can go 240 miles
an hour it has 550 horsepower four
valves per cylinder twelve sylla's but
if there's that governor not letting the
gas go for you ain't going on 55 yeah
that's what a limiting belief does it
stops you from charging forward when you
should and caused you to move back when
you shouldn't and we all have them the
courage and they started getting
inserted in our heads with more yeah big
you know we all stop Bowl on day one and
then came day two when our parents
started spoon feeding us limiting
beliefs sometimes you know they meant
well they just didn't know because you
know one of the things that I'm a big
believer is that we were not only given
our owner's manual my brain is an
immensely powerful computer and this is
you know no bye-bye pretty much
everybody in the self-development
through the top people dr. Richard
Bandler I trained with a great one my
mentors and a brilliant guy and the
first thing he said to me is you know
you never got in your owners manual
Jordan and because that you don't
realize that the world around you that
you take it is reality it's really not
it's subjective the reality I'm looking
at it's just subjective I could
interpret things out I want I can have
the beliefs that that that that empower
me and I can shed the beliefs that
disempower me so the first thing I do
when I meet somebody I work when I coach
really wealthy people some stars in
Hollywood the first thing I do is go
through what their limiting beliefs are
yeah and you're gonna route them out and
it's not difficult you gotta you can't
just Ruth make and replace them with
empowering beliefs we just took the
opposite belief if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the LinkedIn
is in the description below the only
thing that stops you from getting what
you want in life is the bull story you
tell yourself rule number five fail
elegantly thou shalt commit thyself to
master a lot of failing elegantly this
is an entrepreneurial tactic which most
young people don't know because they
haven't failed yet really failed there's
two ways to fail in life in business
it's all about business you can fail
elegantly or you can fail miserably okay
failing elegantly is a way of going
about starting a business while
launching that new division of a company
that allows you to test out an idea or a
concept quickly to get your readers
right over all of the work shows work
without losing a fortune but that wasn't
a lot of time versus failing miserably
when you lose tons of money it takes a
lot of time and you end up with nothing
but a bankruptcy now I in when I was 22
years old and I lost my first real
business I went bankrupt
it was the meat and seafood business I
start with one truck I agree to 26
trucks was making a ton of money I
thought I was making every mistake a
young entrepreneur can make I was over
expanding I was growing but with credit
I was undercapitalized wasn't screening
out my employees before anyone I was out
of business and I failed miserably lost
everything in declared bankruptcy
nowadays when I'm approached with an
idea and I like it I'm gonna test the
idea I'll do it in a way that a if I'm
wrong I don't lose much money well
better yet I'll use other people's money
seriously I'll always take it an
investor and make less on the upside if
it means I can protect myself on the
downside and be I always structure my
tests so I get my reads as quickly as
possible so I know quickly the
information and then I could change my
approach and try again
change my approach and sure enough by
doing that again and again eventually
you'll hit on the right formula I don't
care how smart you are it's so rare that
when you go into business or you try
something new that you get it right the
first time
the first evolution of the idea is not
usually the right one and what will you
see that all through history businesses
at the business where they all are now
making money not on how they thought
they'd make money it's some evolution of
the idea if you fail miserably you'll
never get the chance by structuring your
test so you can fail elegantly you can
test test again and so forth rule number
six maintain your ethics often you think
when you're younger or even you're old
if you haven't had this this lesson
taught you the hard way is that I could
be half pregnant when it comes to ethics
notice I could be ethical but and maybe
I could step over the line balance and
get away with it the problem with that
is that when you step over the ethical
line once your line of ethics moves a
bit mmm so next time you step over
you'll step a bit further away further
so with me you know I became
desensitized to essentially right and
wrong behavior and it's very easy I'm
Walsh you and a lot of people as you as
you found out in 2007 it wasn't just me
everyone
Oh even but 50 times bigger than where
you live some of these guys cost a lot
of people my you know I always say
everyone's doing it that's the old
excuse surely do it you sure I did what
I did it was wrong but the point was
it's very easy to point say well
everyone's doing it so you have to
that's such a good you have to maintain
your ethics you really do this no how do
you do that very simple it really is
very simple you still take the first
step Kotter that's it and that's the
secret there's no way you could take a
kid like just take a step and a blur
than be a good person it's very very
hard rule number seven don't settle for
average I'm a believer okay that the
enemy of greatness in life is good
here's the problem when people are going
through life if things are okay
they aren't feeling enough pain to make
a change it's like if I say to you right
now I say okay everybody raise your
hands as high as you possibly I do it
everyone raise your head as far as you
possibly can right now every dinner
please hi as you got now just a little
bit higher a little higher
what the [ __ ] is that right
I said I bet the first times it raised
as high as you can oh hello if you
really mean it it's that level above
where your comfort zone is that's where
I want you to shoot for don't go through
life burning at 10 watts or 50 B a
hundred watt person and burn bright
don't settle for average you know in the
movie there's no nobility in poverty
right well this is not a poverty crowd
right no it is they're probably end up
in poverty but don't go through life
whatever average means you don't let
that be your life rule number eight
master your state there are certain
states of mind certain emotional states
that lead people to massive poverty
states like fear like greed uncertainty
confusion overwhelmed then there are
other states that set you up to be
massively successful states of certainty
the states of compassionate it's of
clarity states of courage right so first
step business you could be great as a
natural medium business skills you know
how to build a company you're a great
salesperson a great marketer but if
you're walking around all day long like
an emotional basket case good luck
trying to be wealthy successful yeah
you'll make money then you'll make bad
decisions because you're in a
disempowered st. you lose money right so
you have to learn not always like a
robot but you have to learn that what it
matters in that key moment you're not
feel to trigger the right state rule
number nine delay gratification let's
just say if you were to change two or
three things for this to have lasted
what would those two or three things be
number one for sure would be the
delaying the gratification the biggest
problem I had there laying the
gratification that's a problem that a
lot of young arguments have and I
learned that the hard way is that good
things take time and there were some
moves I made that made me a lot of money
in the short term but then created
problems to be over the long term and
for example like Steve Madden shoes is
one of my companies right I remember how
he's the majority shareholder of Steve
Madden shoes if I had not had that
problem from all the stuff I did earlier
I would have made seven hundred million
a billion dollars just over that
versus making 2030 million dollar cuz I
was forced to sell it too early right
it's one example and there's so many
other examples just like that where
first is if I would have not gotten in
trouble I would have made the dot-com
boom and been positioned to have the
biggest firm out there during internet
craze I would've made billions off of
that so while I made a little bit of
extra money sooner it cost me a lot more
with little talk by not playing that
sort of long game playing the short game
and I think that's a big mistake a lot
of people make and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is stand up for yourself
Jordan did you actually feel that the
film depicted you accurately or did it
did it create a hero that didn't deserve
to be a hero it's a movie it's a guilty
pleasure more than anything and it's not
meant to be a moral judgement it's meant
to basically make no moral judgment this
is exactly what Marty Scorsese said he's
not there to judge the characters he's
he had to put a story on screen and let
the people who watch it draw their own
conclusions she could be offended so one
else could clap and say it's the
greatest thing in the world now I can
tell you I get hundreds of emails a day
from people around the world who've
either read the book or seen the movie
ninety-eight percent of them are
incredibly positive empowering great
emails they saw the movie they got it
they Wow the motivation was great the
sales was great but I know the mistakes
you made I never want to do that I can
learn from the bad as well as the good
two percent of them are morons so you
don't want to do quaaludes and have sex
with hookers okay and those people are
[ __ ] all right now now frankly if
you're if you're sitting in this
audience right now and you can't go to
see the wolf of Wall Street and realize
that it's bad there's something wrong
with you this is you're fundamentally
screwed up it's obvious that's not meant
to this is some stuff glamorous yes
drugs is glamorous money's glamorous sex
is glamorous does that mean it's what
you want to do with your life it's in
other words if it's temptation it's part
of the human condition and it's
entertainment so I think that you know
to make so much like people will go to
the movie and that's what's gonna cause
them to be good or bad well here's the
thing when I looked at Wall Street
I idolized Gordon Gekko and the biggest
problem I have with it is you didn't
take the fall in the in the movie Wall
Street money ended up on top
and perhaps we would have fallen in the
movie I would have felt differently at
the end he was you never knew what
happened at least in the wolf of
wallstreet
I lose everything my wife is destroyed I
go to jail so I think a smart person can
go to see this movie and get what it's
about I think I get people more credit
than that I just do Kelly the 98% of the
people who write supportive letters to
Jordan does that horrify you or do you
actually think that no I don't think
your story is a movie or sir I mean
we're living this story right now I
don't think there are many people who
look at poor Jordan Belfort and think
wow this is a cautionary tale he sold
out the 92nd Street Y he's going out of
45 city tour and he's got a TV series
that he's but what but what is but why
is it so you look at you're looking very
black and white though but because I did
that because I've turned my life around
over the last years I was out committing
crimes right now people want to believe
Redemption this world maybe some don't
most do most people want to believe in
second chances
they want to believe in Redemption they
people go through life and make mistakes
and want to come back from that and when
they look at my life now and say this
guy made all these mistakes and look how
he's living his life today it gives them
hope okay and if you want to live in a
world with is no hope and if you make a
mistake you're done it's game over and
then that's everybody said what my
belief you're right but I think that's
why that's you're right he's right let
me just say I agree and in the reason
why people press you on your finances
and everything is because there's not a
real sense that this is a redemption
story there's a sense that this is a
story of wow look at this thing I did
the time that I served but I turned it
around now and now I'm telling you about
it and like people don't press me
journalists do know because they want to
write bad news because bad news sells
more than good news bottom line okay
no one ever no one outside of journals
ever asked me but they're but
journalists can't ask me if they want
but it's cuz they want to sell
newspapers they make a stereo where
there is none let me put it this way if
there was a Wall Street billionaire
tomorrow that said you know what I don't
I don't want Jordan Belfort to get this
publicity I'm gonna pay back the two
hundred million dollars to everyone who
was affected so that nobody ever has to
pay another dime to hear his story
people would want to hear you more about
that they'll make the story even more
sensational so you
people love this store this is what I'm
saying but they love you're missing the
point you related to the it's not just
the money it's about the most up it's
about someone who lived a life was
almost dying every single they had a
massive drug addiction had insane talent
in certain aspects of business misused
it manipulated people destroyed his own
life was able to come it's a story that
is it's very extremely you're selling
successfully that story now well why
would I show you someone successful what
I'm saying is I don't understand I'm
just saying we live in America right yes
but I think people would like to see you
selling Bibles really or someone see me
sell Bob I don't know you're talking
about look at it do you think do you
think I could be a good Bible salesman
by the way now I've got a special bonus
clip from Jordan on how to stay on the
right path that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that is some for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to delay gratification
to chase your goals number two where do
you need to stand up for yourself and
number three where do you need to stop
settling for average I mean because
people always have to wonder can a tiger
change its stripes change the spot yeah
whatever
you know whatever the zebra you know
whatever you want a lot of uses the
analogy I mean can people really do they
really change I mean is there a question
and here's that the answer I think the
answer is yes but very very infrequently
and the way that relates to myself is I
don't really view myself as a leopard
who changed these spots in fact I
started off good
I was raised well by a family that had
the highest ethical standards
so I started off as a good boy I didn't
go into the world sociopath I went into
Wall Street and allowed myself to get
corrupted by greed and drug addiction so
it wasn't like I know is this awful
human being from this thought I was a
good kid that did everything right then
well in school and I was really supposed
to go one
took off left turn Albuquerque somehow
and ended up in this place where I was
doing things I never thought I'd do
associating the people I'd never thought
an associate with and it all seemed
perfectly okay so one transition wasn't
so much from this awful human being to
this pillar of the community I started
off as a pillar of the community took
this left turn Albuquerque and then kind
of got my Krampus back later in life and
that's really more there's a real more
accurate description of Mike on my
journey
if you want more jordan belfort check
out the top 10 rules video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there most people have goals in life and
we would Brooke think you got to be
goal-oriented that's the first mistake
the beliefs that we have really control
our actions